there's strangers nearby  no it's just us i'm scared  there's nothing to be scared of no one's  gonna mess with you kid  what about that one that serves a major  and how about that big bright one  is it earth very good  did you ever see a whale no how about  an elephant earth isn't what it once was  is that why you left we left because we  wanted something more  very lucky to have this place  [Music]  do you see anything  remy  [Music]  you have ready  [Music]  [Music]  mom  this place doesn't belong to you  i've come a long way i'm here to stay  i know how to get this place back on its  feet  and i can protect you but you can leave  if you are  mom we can leave now no rem  can't  so you want to know what's out there  nothing  there's nowhere else left  see these other settlements all gone  the sooner that you accept it just you  know you realize  [Music]  we have everything we need right here  you